the media
want us to hear something different from
joe biden than what joe biden said
they want to rewrite what the president
said
they want to rewrite the studies about
the covid vaccines
and they really want us to eat bugs this
is one of the big
propaganda pushes from the establishment
from the libs from the world economic
forum from hollywood celebrities from
liberal politicians and from the
establishment media for whatever reason
they really
really want you to eat bugs
the future of food is being
revolutionized by science
as new research helps bring unexpected
ingredients to the table it kind of
tastes like shrimp they have this
seafood
quality to them it reminds you of like a
frito or a chip just like crunchy and a
little oily and a little salty and they
taste like popcorn a very smooshy taste
like a pudding almost
like a pudding if pudding were a
disgusting bug
oh hey it tastes like a frito if a frito
were a gross disgusting dirty filthy bug
that you're not supposed to eat
why are they doing this well they're
they're doing this
and they tell you why they're doing this
they're doing this because of global
warming
global warming is really bad
and people keep having babies especially
all those dirty poor brown people in the
foreign countries where we've tried
we've tried our best to stop them from
having children we've tried to sterilize
them we've tried to
give them contraception we've tried to
promote abortion in their countries but
unfortunately their population problem
keeps growing so says bill gates so says
the liberal establishment around the
world darn these guys keep having so
this is going to be a big issue we've
got to get all the poor people to eat
bugs
do you think do you really think
that
bill gates is going to be eating bugs
i don't think so
do you think that clash fob
and his friends at in davos at the world
economic forum do you think they're
going to sit down to a nice big bowl of
bug porridge
i don't think so
do you think the characters the world
leaders who made it down to jeffrey
epstein's island
and had nice nice fun bacchanals down
there do you think they were eating bugs
no they were doing lots of creepy things
but eating bugs was not one of them no
the bugs are not for them
the bugs are for you
just like when the liberal elite says
that people need to they need to stop
living in these single-family homes
that's why they're going to change the
zoning in san francisco that's why
they're changing the zoning in lots of
cities it's just not it's not efficient
it's not good for the environment you
you're going to have to now live in a
duplex or a quadruplex or a big
apartment building and you're going to
have to live in a tiny little apartment
and that's just important for the
environment
they're not going to live in tiny little
apartments that's just for all of us
that's for all all the rest of us
they're listen you're gonna need to you
shouldn't be flying on airplanes as much
you shouldn't be driving as much gas is
gonna the price of gas really needs to
go up not only is it going up because of
the mismanagement of the world by people
like joe biden and the rest of them
they they want it to go up barack obama
when he was running for president 2008
he said my climate plan will involve
raising the price of gas that is
intentional you have to do that to force
people to get electric cars or to stop
driving entirely and take a bicycle or
take public transportation take a bus
take a train
you have to do that do you think that
the elite are doing that do you think
the elite are eating bugs in their
studio apartment that they're paying out
the nose for that they don't own they're
just renting and then they're getting on
the subway is that what they're doing no
of course not they're eating filet
mignon in their gigantic mansions while
they fly on private jets for very very
short flights flying all over the world
it's you
you're the one that needs to cut back
i'm not going to eat the bugs i'm going
to make you a promise right now i will
never
eat the bugs
ever
oh they're a good source of protein
don't care oh no the cows are releasing
methane
okay i don't care i don't care at all i
am going to eat the steak i'm going to
eat good ranchers in particular but i'm
going to eat all sorts of meat i'm not
going to eat the bugs but what's the
rationalist reason michael it's good
protein well because when i eat i'm not
just i'm not just a machine
taking in protein so that i can continue
to function
i'm not just some animal sticking my
face in a feed sack so that i can chow
down on the gruel and go back and work
at the widget factory i'm a human being
you are a human being we live at least
at the moment in civilization and it is
very very uncivilized to eat the bugs
and more broadly it's uncivilized to
just view food to view dining it's such
a central human activity
as just a way to get calories in there
so you can go back and work
work for whom work for
the elite that are not eating the bugs
we need to suffer
so the elite can thrive we need to cut
back and pull back and stop doing and
just to shut up and stay home
so the elite can thrive this is what
buddha judge
who was in fact you want to talk about
man as machine this guy was in fact
constructed in a laboratory at langley
i'm convinced of that no one can
convince me otherwise i think it was
when george h.w bush was the cia
director he under he he initiated a very
important project it was the build a
buddha judge project and they got all
the screws right and they finally and
then he just one day like frankenstein's
monster he got up he was animated he
said hi hi there hey guys hey what is it
really good that gas prices are really
high
that's really good so because then we
can all drive teslas and uh then that'll
just be great won't it so pete buddha
judge shows up he's in congressional
testimony
and buddha judge
says this is really great that yeah
there's a little bit more pain on the
gas prices but now people can buy
electric cars
the more pain we are all experiencing
from the high price price of gas the
more benefit there is for those who can
access electric vehicles
and who
i can't believe he said it
he just said i hadn't even listened to
the clip that closely last night when i
first came across it he just said
exactly what i said he just said the
quiet part out loud
what did i just say i just said
all the people have to suffer so the
elite can thrive and he actually said
on c-span cameras well yeah yeah you all
the poor all the little people need to
have pain at the gas tank so that it's a
benefit the pain of the people at the
gas tank is a benefit for those of us
who have teslas
who has electric cars
rich people
wealthy people have teslas
normal people don't have teslas yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's really it's really
great and pete is astonished that anyone
would object to this
i'm still astonished that that some
folks uh and i felt this uh specifying
in congress yesterday um some folks seem
to really uh struggle to let go of the
status quo
yes pete we do some do i think they
gotta send him back to langley and fix a
couple bugs cause it's he's
malfunctioning a little bit he's almost
human it's that kind of uncanny valley
he's almost human but he's not quite
there yet
i'm astonished that some people
don't want to let go of the status quo
what he's saying is i'm astonished that
there are people who are in any way
conservative
i'm astonished that people
like their country like their community
like their way of life like their car
like their society like their money like
their property
like their family like
well i'm just astonished maybe pete
buddha judge doesn't like our country
maybe people judge doesn't like our way
of life
i do
i do i don't want to change everything i
don't want to completely upend and
change everything i don't want to live
in a pod i don't want to eat the bugs i
don't want to consume a bunch of cheap
chinese crap i don't want to lose my
political rights i don't want to upend
every single institution i don't want to
change the meaning of man and woman i
don't want to change all my language
like the
american version of north korean state
tv told me to do i don't want i don't
want to do that
you know i don't want to do that and i
don't want you to make me do that pete
buddha judge
or klaus schwab
or dr fauci
or any of these freaking government
technocrats who
who have a much higher opinion of
themselves than we have of them i don't
want to do
any of that i want these people to fail
i want pete bootaj to fail in his job i
want joe biden to fail that i think
that one seems to be a little bit easier
i don't want there to be any sort of
great reset i don't want them to change
the way that we eat and live and
interact with each other and even view
ourselves in our own human nature i want
these people to lose i want to win and i
do think though they have a ton of
institutional power i think the
political winds the the the
understanding of those ordinary people
that they want to force to eat all the
bugs i think
those winds are moving entirely in our
direction
guys i am so close to hitting a million
subscribers and that's going to make me
feel really great and then i'm going to
get a big gold play button and then i'm
going to put it up right outside my
office and i'm going to i'm going to
make sure that everybody walks by and if
they only have that silver youtube play
button i will i will mock and deride
them i will make them feel small i will
i will laugh and go far in their face
so please help me to have that pleasure
subscribe ring the bell we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]